didn't we what did we do for story time  marty what did you do this week  hailing from merced california  you know him by the name  dope as yola  let's get this adventure started  it's time  for  story  time  [Applause]  [Music]  yo this [ __ ] bruce buffer guys  what's good you ready for my last  section  [ __ ] giveaway time we've never  really done that on this channel are you  [ __ ] ready  marty and i decided since it's the last  the first episode of the year it's new  year's eve to right now  and i think this comes out the third  it's the last episode of the our first  episode of the year  uh we want to start it off right we want  to start it off fun we're going to start  off with saying [ __ ] thank you  [Music]